ahora sí ya vamos a resolver este
circuito lo primero que vamos a hacer es
sustituir los valores que ya conocemos
en esta ecuación y para eso vamos a
necesitar un poquito más de espacio
entonces empecemos por aquí
v1 ya calculemos que son 15 volts lo
colocamos por aquí 15 volts entre r1
pero tenemos por aquí que erre 1 es
igual a 4000 oms así es que ponemos por
aquí 4000
- v 2 pero b 2 sigue siendo una
incógnita entonces la dejamos por aquí b
2 que se está dividiendo entre r 1 que
son 4000 oms 4000
y luego otra vez menos de dos que
todavía no sabemos cuánto vale entre r 2
pero r 2 sabemos que son 2000 oms 2000
oms y finalmente restamos iese que son
3000 amperes pero lo vamos a poner del
otro lado así es que todo esto tiene que
ser igual a 3000 amperes queremos un
poco más de espacio y entonces pasamos
esto para acá nos queda esto igual a
3000 amperes menos 15 volts entre 4000
oms y por aquí factor izamos de 2 y nos
queda menos de 2
1 entre 4000 oms más 1 entre 2000 oms
estoy haciendo todo esto paso por paso y
ahora sí vamos a continuar por aquí para
que estos dos tengan el mismo
denominador multiplicamos numerador y
denominador por 2 y entonces nos queda
que menos de 2
1 2 3
entre 4000 oms 4
es igual a 3000 amperes menos 15 entre
cuatro son 3.75 y volts entre 1.000 o
más o sea entre kilos oms son mili
amperes entonces nos queda que menos de
2 es igual a 3 - 3.75 milián pérez o sea
menos 0.75 mili amperes y todo eso ahora
lo tenemos que multiplicar por cuatro
mil oms entre 34 mil oms entre 3 estos
signos menos los podemos eliminar y
entonces punto 75 entre 3 son punto 25
por 4 es 1 por lo que nos queda que b 2
es igual a 1 y luego tenemos mil por uno
entre mil eso se cancela también es uno
y amperes por oms son volts
y listo ya lo encontramos aquí tenemos
los dos voltajes de nodos de 2 es igual
a un volt y b 1 es igual a 15 volts por
lo que ya resolvimos las ecuaciones y ya
con estos dos podemos encontrar todos
los voltajes de todos los elementos y
todas las corrientes así es que esta es
la primera aplicación que vemos del
método de voltajes de nodos pero hay
otra cosa que te quiero enseñar muy
importante acerca de este método
dibujemos por aquí nuevamente el
circuito lo que hicimos en este circuito
fue asignar voltajes de nodos de uno es
el voltaje en este nodo b 2 es el
voltaje en este otro nodo y dijimos que
este nodo era nuestro nodo de referencia
ahora aquí podemos ver otra cosa súper
interesante acerca de este método y es
el hecho de que nunca utilizamos la ley
de voltajes de kirchhoff ni en este lazo
ni en este otro y bueno en el fondo eso
es porque estamos utilizando estos
desde nodos que ya traen consigo toda la
información que nos podría dar la ley de
voltajes de kirch o bueno pero para ver
esto con más claridad por aquí vamos a
poner el voltaje de este elemento el
voltaje del resistor r1 que tiene su
terminal positiva por aquí y su terminal
negativa por acá por aquí también nos
gustaría poner el voltaje de este
elemento el resistor r2 pero resulta que
el voltaje de elemento de este resistor
es exactamente igual a b2 y eso es
porque está conectado a este nodo que es
el nodo de referencia pero bueno en este
caso tanto el nodo como el resistor
tienen exactamente el mismo voltaje y
ahora sí vamos a escribir la ecuación de
bbk empezando desde este punto del lazo
por aquí nos falta poner s empezamos por
aquí y le damos la vuelta a este lazo en
este sentido y lo que nos dice la ley de
voltajes de kirchhoff
que como aquí tenemos un aumento de
voltaje tenemos que sumar bs y luego por
aquí tenemos una caída de voltaje así es
que restamos pr1 y finalmente tenemos
aquí otra caída de voltaje de b2 así es
que restamos b2 y esto tiene que ser
igual a cero esto es lo que nos dice la
ley de voltajes de kirchhoff bueno pero
en esta ecuación podemos escribir todo
en términos de los voltajes de nodos
porque el voltaje de un elemento es la
resta de los voltajes de nodos
adyacentes entonces esta ecuación se
transforma en bs menos
vr uno es de uno menos de dos y uno
menos de dos préstamos de dos menos de
dos y eso tiene que ser igual a cero
pero por cierto bs es igual a b1 cierto
porque a partir del nodo de referencia
tenemos únicamente un aumento de bs de
voltaje para llegar a este nodo entonces
esto se convierte en b
1 - b1 b2 menos b 2 igual a cero y si
nos fijamos en esta ecuación b 1 se
cancela con b 1 y luego menos menos b 2
es simplemente b 2 que se cancela con
menos de 2 así es que esta ecuación la
que nos da la ley de voltajes de
kirchhoff es inmediatamente cierta por
lo que no nos aportan nada de
información toda la información que nos
podría aportar ya la estamos usando al
utilizar los voltajes de nodos con
respecto a algún otro nuevo
siempre en todos los circuitos sucede
exactamente lo mismo por eso es que no
la utilizamos así es que este es un
asunto bastante interesante acerca del
método de voltajes de nuevos nos da una
forma muy eficiente de escribir las
ecuaciones que necesitamos únicamente
escribimos y resolvemos las ecuaciones
que nos da la ley de corrientes de
kirchhoff y es un método tan bueno que
simuladores de circuitos como por
ejemplo tal vez hayas escuchado hablar
de spikes al igual que spies casi todos
los simuladores de circuitos utilizan
este método de voltajes de nodos para
hacer sus cálculos